[Applause]
happy friday my fellow funky friday
folks
what a crazy week it's like one of
hemmer's hot tub parties
bad things are happening but it's okay
cause we're all in this together
[Laughter]
first last night's town hall
what did we get from joe
an incoherent jumble of memories and
confused looks but the best
impersonation of beavis and butthead's
pornholio
in history
what the hell was that
but there was more
forty percent of all products coming
into the united states of america on the
west coast go through
uh los angeles and uh and uh um uh um
what am i doing here the long beach long
beach thank you do you have plans to
visit the southern border
i've been there before and i haven't i
mean i know it well i guess i should go
down but what you see is wages are
actually up
freedom
i have the freedom to kill you
my guess is you'll start to see gas
prices come down
as we get by and going into the winter i
mean excuse me in the next year in 2022.
i must tell you i don't have a near-term
answer mr president
there's two famous guys in this audience
here
maybe they were beavis and butthead
well that was the opposite of comforting
it seems his only strategy is to deflect
from our current misery to promising
more misery
well that and fake stories about trains
a lot of the folks in amtrak became my
family not a joke
angelo negri was from you remember ranch
ange came up to me one day when i was
when they just had announced that i had
flown
uh one million some x number of miles on
air force aircraft
and ange comes up and i'm getting in the
car and he goes joey baby what do you do
and i thought the secret service was
gonna shoot him i said no no no he's
good he's good
true story true story
rambling about trains from a human train
wreck
sorry the only biden who knows about
rails
is hunter after he snorted a few fresh
ones
so as america worries joe tells a
debunked story about a dead amtrak
worker this guy's memory is so bad he's
plagiarizing his own lies
as for the supply chain fiasco we did
that story last week but like the
president's memory it's only gotten
worse
empty shelves escalating prices panic
cat can't even buy hair
she's the true victim
still nothing changed and why because it
doesn't affect the politicians the rich
the activist class the very
who are responsible for this mess but it
affects you measly country bumpkins and
you don't rate
i mean when was the last time you were a
designer dressed to a gala event
well for me it was it was thursday
but i digress
sure they dragged buddha judge out of
his fort made of marshmallows and
kittens to make a statement
but he offered nothing but sorry you're
stuck with it he's clever but he's no
leader he's eddie haskell
eddie haskell from leave it to beaver
except he doesn't like the beav
what
never watch the show
now i got nothing against paternity
leave
sorry it's mayor pete that gave
paternity leave a bad name taking off a
few months
it's not like he's octo mom he didn't
have eight kids by c-section
getting a cushy federal perk-filled
position and then bailing for two months
as the country languishes who do you
think you are
kamala harris
hell i didn't even bail in my first year
at college and that was after realizing
it was a holiday inn express
i thought that was funny when i wrote it
fact is no one is in charge and no one
cares
biden is a big rickety trojan horse
being dragged into your living room by
jen sackey susan rice and ron claim but
there are no warriors inside just dust
to put us in the halloween mode this
presidency is the headless horseman it's
not a costume it's real and the cobwebs
for the decorations come from inside
biden's head
you know how you can tell no one's in
charge where are those infamous
executive orders that biden unleashed
when he got in remember how that was
meant to show he was in charge when
really it was all symbolic
take the border crisis all he wanted was
to uh reverse trump-era policy let the
new policy fail then slightly revert
back to trump's and act like he saved us
from the disaster that he needlessly put
us in now with this massive crisis
nothing he could do something but he
won't
and speaking of trump he would have
nuked the supply chain crisis like it
was a hurricane
the same way he solved north korea the
middle east with abraham the abrahamic
accords and of course the vaccines he
would have targeted the issues and blown
them up like they were solimani on the
way to the airport
with the supply chain he would have
created a warp speed in a trucker hat
just with his hell's angels connections
alone the shelves would already be
teeming with christmas toys
oh wait that's right his tweets were
sometimes abrasive so let's replace him
with a cross between gilligan and
thurston howell the third
the result biden remorse
with no one claiming responsibility for
solving this problem not pete not joe
not even kamala she's too busy avoiding
the immigration crisis even migrants
don't run from the border like she does
meanwhile we found out that this clown
show merrick garland had breezily
targeted domestic terrorists i.e parents
based on a fact-free letter from a
left-wing group that had colluded with
the government beforehand so it was all
manufactured this guy's dirtier than
dana perino's mouth after two shots of
fireball
he also says he gets most of his info
from the news i guess meaning cnn which
explains his empty head he didn't know
about the attack on the department of
the interior or the rape in loudoun
county because cnn only reports news
that protects a coddled audience with
room temperature iqs
the politicians quote the media and the
media quotes the politicians round and
round they go
i won't use the crude expression for
that kind of circle
but i don't want jeffrey toobin to get
excited
so like joe and mayor pete
merrick's another headless horseman no
ideas no nothing just threatened his
stuff and leaving behind piles of horse
crap for the peasants to shovel up but
now he kicked a hornet's nest with his
bare feet you think black lives matters
or the tea party was a movement
try millions of scorned parents from all
economic groups with more racial
diversity than a 1980s benetton ad
garland kicked the mama bear and the
bear has the temperament of a
constipated bernie sanders
now parents may be disadvantaged as
activists they're new added and also
they're too busy to occupy a park block
a highway or poop on a sidewalk
they have jobs real ones but they also
have kids who i hate
but i get it you get between parents and
your children you start a battle that'll
be over quicker than a typical joe biden
work day
the headless horseman should be scared
he claimed he was going to unify a
country and he did against him
welcome tonight's guest
she only goes by one name like madonna
geraldo and psoriasis host of kennedy on
fox business kennedy
he started and sold 15 companies in the
time it took for this introduction
author of wokee the vikramaswamy
he's so white he can't be worn after
labor day foxy's contributor tom chalu
and when life gives her lemons she runs
down fifth avenue squeezing them in
people's eyes fox news contributor cat
tim
so kennedy is it me or does it feel like
america is on autopilot like we don't
have any plans to fix any big problems
it's like they're pretending like it's
still summer
yes and but that's that's the one common
thread that runs through this
administration is no one takes
responsibility for anything no one uh
maturely acknowledges that there are
problems to begin with
they just sit there in a holding pattern
just waiting for the weather to clear so
they can land and not have to discuss
any of this ever again and it doesn't
matter what it is like inflation
afghanistan immigration all of these
things are not going away
and blaming people for ordering
treadmills or blaming americans for not
getting out of afghanistan those are not
solutions to ongoing crises and it's the
kind of thing where everyone thinks and
and i am one of those people that joe
biden is run by committee right he is
when he's in a good mood but when he's
in a bad mood and he's still got you
know mush brain he's like no i'm still
going to be the one in charge i'm not
going to be the next guy and i'm not
going to let you do stuff there
and uh it leaves the country in a real
lurch yeah it's like
it's like they treat every problem like
a one-night stand
it's a bad idea it happened but then
they pretended it didn't happen let's
just move on vivek uh you when he said
what am i doing here that could be a
slogan for 2024.
it's deep existential question yeah i'm
wondering the same thing i mean i'm
going to make a prediction though greg
and it's not necessarily from joe biden
it's from the people who manage him the
more we see supply chain shortages the
more inflation we see the more foreign
policy disasters we see the more woke
smoke we're going to start hearing from
this administration too because that is
what this is all about is not just
insulating themselves from
accountability but distracting people
changing the subject and now as this
administration goes south i predict
right now mark my words we're going to
see more declarations about racial
inequity we're going to see more
discussion about transgenderism we're
going to see more discussion about the
kinds of cultural issues that are
designed to distract the public from
their own failures and you know what the
magic trick might have worked in the
beginning but i think as people start to
actually pay more in their credit card
pay more at the pump i don't think
they're going to fall for it anymore
yeah i'm actually pretty i think this
could be the medicine we need actually
is that we put the guy in office suffer
the consequences a little bit and then i
think that'll actually get us past
cultural problems like all those uh
politically correct woke-ism platitudes
you can indulge in in times of luxury
but in times of panic they are exposed
for what they are utterly worthless and
actually destructive because it keeps
symbolic action always keeps you from
real action which i tell tom all the
time
uh i like joe always says the buck stops
here
but then he blames somebody else the
buck stops here over there
and it's like which buck that's the
thing there's so many things yes there
are so many things going wrong i mean we
didn't even talk about all
of his restrictions on liberty that's
what
you know we watch him bumbling around
the stage and there's something funny
about it and it it makes you think that
he's a harmless figure it would be one
thing if he were just doing nothing and
the world was getting worse yeah but
he's actually doing things right he's
forcing masks on children and adults
that's not good he's forcing injections
on people that's not good he's shutting
down the economy i mean the shutdowns
they hurt this country so badly so he's
doing real harm but he looks like mr
magoo so we forget that he's really
hurting the question thank you so much
right don't smear mr magoo
he didn't mean it voiced by jim backus
yes who thurston thurston iii whoa
wow my entire brain is just on fire
right now it's a simulation it is a
stimulation everything's a simulation
cat what is interesting to me and i
assume it's interesting to you because
you work for me
i've never seen a leader so nonchalant
about bearing bad news like it's almost
like it is not his problem it's your
problem suck it up lower your
expectations it's kind of weird i mean
it's an effective and effective tool
actually if you want to give someone bad
news you act like it's no big deal
hoping they match the mood i've used
that method repeatedly really yeah
examples please well i'd rather not
because then my all my work would be for
nothing that is true um but i will say
the most alarming thing about the town
hall is remember last week they let us
all know earlier this week that all the
questions would they would be
pre-screened
there were no surprises there yeah and
that still happened
he forgot the name of the port of long
beach and that's what it's called the
port of long beach
and
yet
how hard is it to remember a long
beach
it's not he knew about all those
questions yes
how does that happen i don't know i
don't know it's interesting what would
have happened if you if they were
spontaneous i would love to watch that
but i mean the scary thing about it is
he was way better on the debates than he
is now and that suggests that this thing
is going in a in a rather quick
direction but i won't uh i'm not a
doctor although i do pretend to be one
on the weekends are you saying that he
was juicing and hopped up on some
hunter's booger sugar yes i think that's
exactly what i was saying kennedy
yes
i'm not saying he wasn't doing an eight
ball before the debates but i'm not not
saying
no that's how you get around the
speculation also if you raise do what
cnn does and raise a question yeah
yes just asking questions yes yes all
right we must move on what a great start
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else